tout un programme un gros challenge
aussi que je me suis lancé aujourd'hui
pour vous
là sur la première photo je dois être
adolescent à ce moment-là sur cette
photo là je ne m'aime pas sur la
deuxième photo non plus
à cette époque là je ne m'aimais pas du
tout sur la troisième
j'avais commencé mes études et je ne
m'aime pas non plus j'ai l'impression
d'être heureux et je suis sûr de m'aimer
mais à cette époque là je me mets
toujours pas la dernière c'était encore
un peu plus tard et pareil à cette
époque là j'étais persuadé de m'aimer
j'étais persuadé d'être épanoui d'aller
bien d'être heureux
mais au fond je ne m'aimais pas et je
suis sûr que ici dans cette salle quand
vous êtes en plus beaucoup d'étudiants
il y en a beaucoup d'entre vous qui sont
persuadés d'aller bien d'être heureux
tout va bien et qui au fond cache des
choses qu'ils empêchent d'être vraiment
eux-mêmes d'être vraiment épanoui et de
vraiment s'aimer c'est normal d'avoir
cette certitude là c'est normal de pas
en avoir conscience et en même temps à
cette époque là j'étais aussi persuadé
que la moustache m'allait bien donc
fait tous des erreurs
aujourd'hui on va suivre un petit plan
on va faire toute cette petite étape
ensemble et voir comment est-ce qu'on
peut faire pour essayer d'aller mieux
d'apprendre à s'aimer et comment ça peut
vous aider dans votre vie pour plus tard
on va commencer par l'introspection
ensuite on va aller chercher des
solutions
on va continuer sur du développement
personnel et on va essayer de pérenniser
ce développement là et voir comment
continuer ça tout au long de sa vie mais
avant ça on va faire un petit constat
on va parler de ce qui se passe dans la
société parce que globalement peut-être
que je vous apprends rien peut-être que
si la société va mal les gens ne sont
pas heureux les gens sont plus en plus
déprimés de plus en plus seuls de plus
en plus anxieux
ce que vous voyez là ce petit classement
à votre avis c'est quoi ce qui arrive en
deuxième place chez les 15-25 ans et en
première place j'ai les 25 35 ans
c'est le suicide c'est la deuxième cause
de mortalité chez les moins de 25 ans
c'est la première cause de mortalité
chez le 25 35 ans et ça reste la
première d'ailleurs pour toutes les
tranches d'âge d'après mais alors
pourquoi pourquoi est-ce que j'en
suicide pourquoi est-ce que les gens
sont aussi mal et pourquoi est-ce qu'on
s'en rend pas compte qu'on a
l'impression qu'au fond tout le monde
est heureux
il y a une écrivain qui s'appelle
Lisbonne qui a écrit ce livre les cinq
blessures qui empêchent d'être soi-même
dans laquelle elle liste le rejet
l'injustice la trahison l'abandon et
l'humiliation comme étant les
principales traumatismes qu'on vit
pendant l'enfance et l'adolescence qui
reste en nous et qu'on va traîner toute
notre vie qui vont finir par nous
gangrener
et par saper complètement le moral ça
fait notre estime de nous-mêmes nous
ralentir sans même qu'on s'en rende
compte jusqu'à commettre parfois les
réparable et moi j'aime bien ajouter la
violence et la peur qui sont deux
traumatismes que moi j'ai vécu
personnellement avec une vie de famille
compliquée il y a des moments où j'ai eu
très peur où j'ai été confronté à de la
violence à des cris à des situations
traumatisantes pour un enfant j'avais un
petit frère que je voulais proposer de
protéger de ça et donc je me mettais en
avant et j'essayais de faire un peu
rempart et ça m'a complètement coupé mon
enfance et couper ma jeunesse
mais c'est marrant parce que dans ces
moments là quand j'allais à l'école
après j'étais toujours le pitre de la
classe et à l'école c'était pareil et
pendant les études supérieures c'était
pareil j'étais celui qu'on entendait le
plus qui faisait le plus de bêtises qui
faisait marrer tout le monde j'étais
président de BDE j'ai fait plein de
choses incroyables et tout le monde
pensait que j'étais la personne la plus
épanouie la plus confiante celle qui
allait le mieux alors qu'au fond j'étais
juste meurtri et j'étais écorché par
tout ce que j'avais vécu et je faisais
tout ça pour essayer de ne pas y penser
et je sais pas que ça
j'avais plein de mauvaises habitudes
mais une partie de ce qui est là et que
vous connaissez sûrement tous et je suis
sûr que beaucoup d'entre vous l'ont
aussi la fuite le fait de ne pas vouloir
faire face à ces problèmes là l'alcool
très bon moyen aussi de oublier
momentanément ces problèmes la drogue le
tabac la malnutrition toutes ces choses
là qui sur le coup nous font du bien et
que sur long terme vous détruisent parce
que en plus de perdre du temps pour
essayer d'aller mieux on s'est beaucoup
de mal à soi beaucoup de mal à son corps
toutes ces petites choses là c'est que
des choses qui vont venir encore
s'accumuler sur le mal-être et les
problèmes qu'on a déjà
alors la première étape c'est de prendre
conscience des problèmes qu'on a
identifié comprendre cette traumatisme
et travailler dessus
travailler dessus pour essayer d'aller
mieux c'est à dire partager ça en parler
se faire aider s'ouvrir aux autres et
dans certains cas dans certains
situations qu'il le nécessitent ne pas
aider à se faire aider par un
professionnel on dira jamais assez mais
parfois juste avoir un psychologue qui
nous accompagne et qui nous aide à
passer ces traumatismes là
c'est très très important bon ça c'est
la première étape ça y est on a fait le
deuil parce qu'on a vécu avant on se
sent mieux mais ça y est on est perdu
dans notre vie et maintenant qu'on a
arrêté de boire de sortir tout le temps
de fumer et j'en passe on se retrouve un
peu sans but alors qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire
deux étapes pour la suite deux types de
valeur premier type de valeur celle que
vous vous accordez à vous même comment
vous allez prendre soin de vous comment
vous allez vous tirer vers le haut et
pour ça on va reprendre toutes les
mauvaises habitudes d'avant et on va
les transposer et les échanger par ça on
va essayer d'échanger la fuite par la
prise de conscience et du bien-être
personnel on va arrêter de boire de
l'alcool tous les soirs et de sortir
tous les week-ends
à se cultiver un peu plus à prendre un
peu plus de temps pour soi pour se
développer on va arrêter le tabac on va
se mettre au sport on va arrêter de
manger n'importe quoi on va commencer à
manger un peu plus sain apprendre un peu
plus prendre son corps ça paraît bateau
ça paraît très très bateau c'est des
conseils qu'on adore donner à tout va de
dire pas plus d'eau mange mieux arrête
de fumer mais qui applique vraiment qui
dans qui entre vous dans cette salle et
derrière votre écran à passer une seule
semaine sans faire les cinq mauvaises
habitudes d'avant et à pratiquer ces
cinq bonnes habitudes
rien que ça c'est déjà quelque chose de
complexe à mettre en place et rien que
ça c'est un très très bon début pour
commencer à aller mieux et commencer à
se faire du bien commencer à avoir
l'impression de prendre soin de soi
comme si on prenait soin de quelqu'un
comme si on prenait soin de la personne
qu'on aime le plus
ensuite
les petits accomplissements et ça c'est
quelque chose que j'adore c'est quelque
chose qui m'a beaucoup aidé qu'on
m'avait conseillé aussi à l'époque et
que je continue d'appliquer tous les
jours
c'est en partie grâce à ça que je suis
devenu entrepreneur qu'est-ce que c'est
les petits accomplissements c'est
simplement donner un rythme à son
développement et à son évolution vous
allez prendre de quoi noter un carnet un
téléphone un logiciel comme Asana ou
notion que j'utilise beaucoup pour le
travail et pour ça et faire deux listes
tout simplement une liste avec vos
compétences et vos accomplissements tout
ce que vous savez déjà faire tout ce que
vous avez déjà accompli tout ce que vous
avez déjà appris tout ce dont vous êtes
fier cette liste là elle va vous aider à
vous valoriser à prendre conscience de
tout le chemin que vous avez déjà
parcouru la deuxième liste les rêves et
les objectifs
vous allez lister toutes les choses que
vous avez envie de faire envie de
découvrir envie d'apprendre et ça peut
être tout et n'importe quoi ça peut être
ne pas fumer la clope du matin ça peut
être lire 10 pages d'un livre ça peut
être apprendre à nouveau sport ça peut
être à prendre une nouvelle langue ça
peut être créer votre entreprise
ça peut être être un peu plus gentil
avec votre frère ou votre sœur tout ce
que vous voulez toutes ces petites
choses qui vont vous rendre fier et vous
donner l'impression d'avancer dans la
vie et le plus important c'est la
temporalité c'est ça rien de noter tout
ça dans un coin et de laisser ça et de
l'oublier vous allez vous mettre un
objectif de temps un week-end une
semaine un mois il faut qu'à chaque fois
au bout de ce temps là il y a une des
lignes de vos rêves et de vos objectifs
qui passent du côté des accomplissements
et des compétences et le but c'est de
déséquilibrer la liste pour remplir la
première et vider la deuxième et vous
allez déjà beaucoup beaucoup mieux vous
sentir après tout ça
et alors ça c'est une partie que j'adore
la cause et c'est le deuxième type de
valeur c'est les valeurs que vous allez
défendre et les valeurs que vous allez
porter parce qu'avoir des objectifs des
rêves et des choses que vous avez en
découvrir c'est bien rajouter une cause
c'est encore mieux ça va vous donner
l'impression d'être plus utile
l'impression de servir à quelque chose
la pression d'agir aussi pour le monde
dans lequel on vit qui va être de plus
en plus mal et alors comment est-ce
qu'on fait ça c'est très simple on va
aller chercher dans son passé on va
aller chercher dans les choses qu'on a
vécues dans les choses qui nous animent
dans les choses qui nous touchent
et on va aller trouver un thème qu'on a
envie de défendre et qu'on a envie de
porter la défense des animaux
l'humanitaire ou comme dans mon cas la
protection des océans
je suis l'apnéiste depuis que je suis
tout petit
j'adore la mer j'adore les ocents
j'adore le poisson le corail j'ai été
terrorisé et horrifié de revoir mes
photos d'enfance à la plage avec ma
grand-mère ou je faisais des châteaux de
sable et où je les faisais tenir en
mettant des déchets des bouteilles
plastiques des capuchons et autres pour
décorer des petits pâtés parce que déjà
à cette époque là c'était déjà un énorme
problème c'était déjà dramatique
maintenant avec les entreprises que j'ai
montées l'ONG que j'ai fondé on lutte
pour ça et j'ai suivi ce parcours là
j'ai soigné mes traumatismes j'ai mis
des objectifs en place dans ma vie je me
suis redonné un rythme de vie j'ai
repris soin de moi et ça m'a donné la
force ça m'a donné l'ambition de me dire
maintenant je suis prêt et je suis
légitime pour défendre une cause et pour
porter des valeurs
ok on est déjà pas mal on a déjà bien
avancé ensuite qu'est-ce qu'on fait
on va donner du sens à sa vie avec tout
ça on va juste prendre conscience que ça
y est bravo vous venez de donner un sens
à votre vie vous venez d'arrêter d'être
juste victime et être dépendant de votre
traumatisme et vos ressentiment qui vous
font juste faire des choses mauvaises
pour vous et ne pas avancer vous pouvez
juste de donner en sens à votre vie avec
tout ça mais c'est pas fini on va aller
encore plus loin
on va apprendre à être soi-même et alors
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire être soi-même
c'est tout simple c'est juste arrêter de
vouloir exister à travers le regard des
autres c'est commencer à être vraiment
soi-même enlever le masque comporte
arrêter d'être un personnage et juste
commencer à se poser la question
et à dire est-ce que je suis tout le
temps sincère dans mes relations dans ma
façon de parler dans ce que j'annonce
pouvoir faire dans la façon dont j'agis
avec les autres et bien souvent c'est
pas le cas bien souvent on vit beaucoup
plus à travers le regard des autres et
l'image qu'on renvoie qu'en étant
réellement soi-même alors qu'est-ce
qu'on fait dans ces cas là pareil c'est
très simple quatre étapes on accepte on
accepte que on n'est pas vraiment
soi-même que dans la conversation d'hier
soir on a admis qu'on faisait quelque
chose alors qu'en fait on savait pas du
tout le faire
on accepte le fait que on a agi d'une
façon qui n'était pas du tout nous on a
essayé d'être quelqu'un d'autre sur le
moment
on analyse pourquoi on l'a fait on prend
du recul pour se dire la prochaine fois
je vais faire mieux et on recommence en
faisant ça vous allez vraiment apprendre
à être vous-même et vous allez vraiment
commencer à vous sentir de plus en plus
épanouie
mieux dans votre peau mieux dans votre
corps
et pouvoir faire un petit bilan sur la
suite parce qu'on a déjà passé pas mal
d'étapes on a déjà bien avancé on a
appris à accepter nos problèmes on a
appris à les traiter on a appris à se
valoriser on a appris à donner du sens
on a appris avec nous-mêmes et alors
c'est quoi la suite logique et c'est là
où c'est facile c'est là où ça devient
vraiment de plus en plus agréable ça va
être de laisser faire le temps et alors
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire laisser faire
le temps ça veut dire que tout le reste
va venir tout seul naturellement en
étant vous-même en ayant des objectifs
et en sachant où est-ce que vous voulez
aller dans la vie vous allez vous
éloigner des personnes toxiques vous
allez vous détacher de toutes les
relations de toutes les situations qui
vous correspondent pas que ce soit vos
études que ce soit des hobbies que vous
avez commencé juste par intérêt et pas
par plaisir personnel vous allez vous
séparer de la personne et qui vous êtes
qui ne vous tire pas vers le haut tout
va se faire tout seul ça va lui revenir
fluide ça va devenir limpide
ça va juste devenir vous-même votre
propre expérience votre parcours de vie
et surtout vous allez apprendre à saisir
les opportunités de la vie
il y a un autre livre que j'ai envie de
vous conseiller qui s'appelle l'éloge de
la chance de Philippe gabier car un
livre qui est incroyable qui nous
apprend une chose toute bête si je
devais vraiment le résumer en une seule
phrase
c'est que les chanceux sont pas des
personnes qui ont plus d'opportunités
que les autres les chanceux c'est
simplement des gens qui ont appris à les
reconnaître et à les saisir tout ce que
vous voulez vous allez faire jusqu'ici
c'est apprendre à être épanoui à être
heureux et être attentif à ce qui se
passe autour de vous
et à saisir les opportunités vous en
avez plein qui vous passent sous le nez
des rencontres que vous faites des
situations que vous rencontrez plein de
choses que vous pourriez transformer en
coup de chance en énorme changement dans
vos vies et vous le faites pas parce que
vous les voyez pas c'est parce que vous
êtes concentrés fermés sur vous-même que
vous n'êtes pas ouvert au monde et à
tout ce qui tourne autour de vous
avec tout ce qu'on a fait jusqu'ici vous
allez voir vous allez devenir un de ses
chanceux où les gens vont dire
franchement le hasard fait bien les
choses vous avez juste lui dire non
c'est moi qui le force le hasard à venir
à moi
ça c'est un vrai chanceux j'espère que
ce sera bientôt
bon
c'est déjà pas mal on a déjà fait une
bonne partie du chemin qu'est-ce qui
reste après
il reste le partage et l'inspiration
typiquement ce que je suis en train de
faire là malgré le fait que on n'a
jamais vraiment fini tout ce travail là
et toutes ces étapes là ça dure toute
une vie c'est quelque chose qui s'arrête
vraiment jamais
mais il y a un moment où on peut
commencer à se dire ça y est je peux
commencer à aider les autres je peux
commencer à aider mes amis aider les
gens que j'aime les aider à se
développer les aider à aller mieux
passer déjà ses premières étapes que moi
j'ai passé pour qu'il puisse me
rejoindre et pour continuer à avancer
ensemble c'est une étape qui est très
plaisante et c'est souvent un piège dans
lequel on tombe au début de vouloir
absolument aider les autres plutôt que
de s'aider soi-même je suis sûr que vous
êtes plein ici à faire ça on fait tous
cette erreur là on va mal on va pas bien
on parle avec un ami qui lui non plus va
pas bien on se dit ok je vais t'aider
fais ça mange mieux ne vois pas l'alcool
arrête de fumer prends-toi en moi
fais-toi des objectifs on rentre chez
soi on se pose dans son lit et
et nous on fait rien
à partir du moment où vous avez fait
toutes ces étapes vous allez devenir
beaucoup plus efficace
vous allez pouvoir vraiment commencer à
aider les autres
vous allez devenir des vrais leaders et
attention quand je parle de leader je
parle de leader du quotidien
un leader c'est quelqu'un qui est
optimiste qui est dynamique qui est
proactif qui va tirer les autres vers le
haut vous allez être le moteur de votre
groupe le moteur des gens que vous aimez
vous allez être la personne qui va se
lever quand tout le monde est sur le
canapé à stressé pour les révisions et à
pas oser se lancer qui va dire allez on
s'y met vous allez organiser les
vacances pour tout le monde
quand tout le monde sera triste déprimé
désespéré à cause d'une situation quelle
qu'elle soit c'est vous qui allez
réconforter les autres alors qu'au fond
c'est vous qui êtes le plus brisé parce
que vous aurez cette force en vous et
que vous aurez envie de tirer les autres
vers le haut avec vous parce que
maintenant que vous aurez fait votre
propre bonheur vous aurez appris à vous
aimer à aller mieux
tout ce qui est pour restera pour être
encore plus heureux c'est que les gens
que vous aimez autour de vous le soir
aussi et ça c'est beau c'est ça être un
vrai leader
et pas forcément être
un grand entrepreneur qui monte des
startups qui veulent des milliards qui
envoient des fusées sur la lune et qui
lancent la nouvelle marque de voiture
électrique vous avez pas besoin de
devenir une sorte de mix entre vous et
Elon Musk
même si
ça peut valoir le coup de mélanger ces
gènes
mais bon
le tout c'est déjà de se concentrer sur
soi le succès des petits objectifs à son
niveau de chercher à avancer chercher à
aller mieux et après on verra pour créer
cette espèce de chimère
plutôt beau gosse
on va conclure sur une phrase que
j'adore
une phrase qui moi me tire vers le haut
tous les jours
une phrase qui dit
apprendre à s'aimer c'est ajouter son
propre nom à la liste des personnes
qu'on admire moi c'est une phrase qui me
touche beaucoup et c'est une phrase qui
veut simplement dire que en évoluant
tous les jours en avançant en se prenant
en main et un moment vous allez prendre
du recul sur votre vie et vous dire je
suis devenu je suis devenu quelqu'un que
j'aurais admiré et que j'aurais idolâtre
et à l'époque il faut que vous deviez
cette personne qui vous semble
inatteignable cette personne qui a
l'impression de tout réussir d'être
épanoui d'être vraiment heureuse de
porter les autres de tirer les autres de
changer le monde de défendre des causes
il faut que vous deviez cette personne
là
il faut que la personne qui vous donne
le plus envie d'évoluer soit vous-même
ce soit la version de vous que vous avez
envie de devenir
on va finir sur quelque chose
pas très positif mais le monde va mal le
monde est dur vous le savez
et le monde va être encore plus dur
covid et crise énergétique les guerres
l'environnement la pollution le monde
est dur mais si vous faites ce travail
là si vous passez toutes ces étapes vous
allez apprendre à vous aimez vous allez
reprendre et évoluer vous allez devenir
ambitieux déterminé vous allez devenir
des vrais leaders et avec toute cette
force là et tout ce qu'on pourra
construire ensemble une fois qu'on a
tous passé cette étape là on aura
peut-être une chance peut-être une
chance de construire un monde meilleur
pour la suite merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]